My toddlers have been asking for marshmallows
ever since we ran out,
so today I decided to surprise them by
making them some salted caramel marshmallows.
I started by making the caramel syrup
by melting down some sugar with some butter
and then slowly adding in some heavy cream.
I let it boil for a couple minutes
and then add some flaky sea salt in
before transferring it over to a glass container
so that it can cool.
Then I move on to making my marshmallows
by combining some water and gelatin
and letting that bloom.
I wanted to keep these sugar free,
so I used honey instead.
Once my honey mixture was hot enough,
I poured it in with the gelatin
and whipped it until it was light and fluffy.
In the meantime,
I dusted my baking dish with some aroot powder
and then spooned the marshmallow fluff into it.
This was all very sticky,
so I made sure my hands were damp before I went in
to smooth it all out.
My caramel sauce had cooled enough,
so I put dollops on it on top of my marshmallow fluff
and then swirled it in.
Sprinkled some flaky sea salt on top
and also some more aero root powder
so it wouldn't stick.
Let that sit for about five hours
and then it was ready to get sliced.
I went with bigger squares
and the caramel on top was so perfect!